EVERYONE I'M GOING TO MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS.
EXCUSE ME A MOMENT I'M GETTING
FEEDBACK SAGA. HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL BE BETTER. YEAH ALL. WE
DALLAS. WE'RE JUST GOING TO
TECHNOLOGICALLY CROP AND DEAL
WITH I JUST TURNED MY
HEADPHONES OFF I THINK. LEVINE
SENT TO- BUT WE WANTED ON RED
RED YELLOW OKAY THE PRESIDENT
OF ONLINE REALLY. RATES AND-
THE U. S. RIGHT NOW FIGURE ONE
OKAY. LET ME TRY ONE MORE TIME
TO SEE A WE'RE HERE IN FEEDBACK.
OKAY ALL RIGHT GIVE US A MOMENT
OUR EVERYONE WHO'S TUNING IN
GIVE US A MOMENT SO WE GET RID
OF THE FEEDBACK AND PROCEED
WITH OUR MEETING. MY FROM THE
SOFT. POWER TO ME ABOUT THIS
OKAY. YEAH OKAY SO CHANGE THE
RULES RULES HERE YEAH CHANGE
MANAGEMENT. ALL ON IT WHICH
TEAMS WHO HE THOUGHT OF. IT AS
POSSIBLE. LIZARDMEN. NINETY
SEVEN TWO. OKAY I THINK WE'RE
THE SOUND OFF ON OUR COMPUTERS.
THE OLDEST SON OF. HELLO MY
COMPUTER. NOTE THAT-
OKAY LET
ME TRY THIS ONE MORE TIME THAT
IS MUCH BETTER SO I'M GOING TO
CALL THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
RULES- TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M GONNA MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
CENTRAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
I'M GOING TO COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. SENATORS
AND SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
ADHERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THISESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS. TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE WE WILL REPEAT THIS
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING SO THAT
THE PUBLIC OUT WILL HAVE ACCESS
AND SEE IT MORE THAN ONCE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON.
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND AGAIN LET
ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AT
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
AND WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS A CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN
AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO PLEASE BE PATIENT.
AND WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF OUR STENOGRAPHER
WHO WORKS VERY HARD I WANT TO
ASK ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES
AND WITNESSES A LIKE. TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY IF I NEED TO
I WILL INTERRUPT YOU TO ASK YOU
TO SLOW DOWN SOMETIMES WE GET
GOING AND WE FORGET. BUT I WILL
INTERRUPT YOU MOMENTARILY TO
ASK YOU TO SLOW DOWN AND THEN
YOU CAN CONTINUE. SO BEFORE WE
BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AS A
REMINDER MEMBERS YOU'LL NEED TO
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES FOR
THE ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME
THAT WE VOTE. AND WITH THAT FAN
OF SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ROATH PRESENT.
HERTZBERG YOUR PREFERRED HERE
LAYARD HERE THEY'RE HERE BATES
YEAH THANKS HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY I AM GOING TO-
ATTEMPT TO DISPENSE WITH SOME
ITEMS AND I WILL READ THE NAMES
OF THE APPOINTEES THAT ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR BUT I WOULD
ASK OUR- THAT WE CONSIDER
PUTTING ITEM TO. OUR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR AND THAT WOULD BE- D. E.
AND F. I WILL TAKE TO D. E. N.
F. AND THAT WOULD BE FOR SARAH
BARTH. R. S. MAY MEHIDY AND
CATHERINE TOY EACH OF THESE
WOULD BE APPOINTED MEMBERS OF
THE STATE PARK AND RECREATION
COMMISSION AND SO I WOULD
INTERNET. THANK YOU ARE MR
MAJORITY LEADER SO ON ITEM TWO
D. E. AND F. MADAM SECRETARY-
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL. GROSS
FIVE ROW FIVE HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE LAYERED. AYE
BATES OF I'D LIKE TO HAVE
STAINED I UNDERSTAND THE THEY
WILL BE HAVING A MEETING ON
FRIDAY THE TWELFTH AND I AM A
LITTLE BIT CONCERNED ABOUT AND
INITIATIVE THEY'LL BE
DISCUSSING AND I WANT TO HEAR
THAT DISCUSSION- I AM MOST
LIKELY SUPPORTIVE OF THEM BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT REGARDING
THE NAMING OF. PARKS AND TRAILS
AND ALL OF THAT THAT I
UNDERSTAND THEIR APPROACH OF
THAT SO- JUST INSTANTIATE THAT
TO LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING THAT
AND THEN MOVING FORWARD- WHEN
THEY'RE UP FOR FINAL VOTE AT.
SESSION THANK YOU SENATOR.
ATKINS I ATKINS AYE. THINK
EITHER FORTY ZERO- THEY ARE
APPROVED. ITEM TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES R. G. N. H. THAT
WOULD BE I SICK HOW PHARAOH'S.
AND STEPHEN NO BOTH MEMBERS OF
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION OUR
MOTION. SENATOR LAYERED THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY. GROWTH I
DROVE BY HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG I'D LAYERED AYE AYE
BATES ALL RIGHT IF I CAN FIND A
CONCERN AND I WILL FINALLY
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY- THAT
WAS UNANIMOUS I WILL ASK FOR A
MOTION ON MIL REFERRALS ITEM
THREE THANK YOU MISTER MAJORITY
LEADER THAT'S REFERENCE OF
BILLS TO COMMITTEE FAN OF
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
ROTHE ALL RIGHT I HERTZBERG
HIGH IT'S FOR A LAYERED HI I
FACE ALL RIGHT. I CAN AYE
ATKINS. ALSO UNANIMOUS THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY SO WITH
THAT WE'LL BEGIN- TODAY'S
HEARING WITH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
WITH ITEM ONE A. WHICH IS
CHARACTERIZED AS DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL. DIRECTOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US I WILL INVITE YOU TO MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS FEEL FREE
TO A KNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. AND AFTER YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. A GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACKNOWLEDGING MY FAMILY WHO
ARE ATTENDING THISHEARING
REMOTELY- WITH ME TODAY IS MY
WIFE VICTORIA MY SON DARREN. MY
DAUGHTER ALYSSA I THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND INTRODUCE
MYSELF TO THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THE PAST TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
I'VE DEDICATED MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE TO CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I BEGAN MY CAREER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND I'VE SPENT THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL. SINCE LAST
JULY HAVE HAD THE HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING OF THE-
SERVING AS A DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AND I'M TRULY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE RECEIVED THIS
APPOINTMENT I GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THE PAST TWELVE
MONTHS HAVE BEEN AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIME FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE PANDEMIC HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED
DIFFERENT SECTORS OF THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE INDUSTRY.
ALL OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
RESPONSE THE PANDEMIC. WE
PROVIDED IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
THOUSANDS OF LICENSEES BY
PROVIDING REGULAR REGULATORY
RELIEF MEASURES INTEMPERATE YOU
FEED EXTENSIONS WE'RE STILL
MISSING AFFECTED TELEWORK MODEL
PROVIDING PROMPT SERVICE AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LICENSEES WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE TO CHANGES ON
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE AS WELL
AS INFORMATION ABOUT BUSINESS
LOANS GRANTS AND FEE WAIVERS
MADE AVAILABLE BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE MINISTRATION.
AND WE CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE A BC LICENSE BUSINESSES
COMPLY WITH STATE HEALTH ORDERS
USING EDUCATIONAL FIELD VISITS
THE WARNINGS BY TAKING EXTRA
STEPS TO SEEK VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE WHEN NEEDED. DURING
THIS PANDEMIC I ENSURE THAT TO
BARK THAT THE DEPARTMENT DID
NOT LOSE FOCUS ON TO OUR ON
GOING PRIORITIES. ENSURED THAT
OUR IT MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
CONTINUED AND SO WE CAN IMPROVE
THE WAY WE INTERFACE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ELECTRONIC
SERVICES. AND SO WE CAN
MAXIMIZE OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY. I ALSO ENSURE THAT
WE MAINTAIN A STRONG PRESENCE
IN PREVENTING YOUTH ACCESS TO
ALCOHOL AND UNDERAGE DRINKING
ENFORCEMENT BROUGHT THE STATE.
AS A PANDEMIC DID NOT CURB
MINORS FROM DRINKING. AS A
DIRECTOR I REMAIN PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S MISSION
OUR PROGRAMS ARE EMPLOYEES IN
THE VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WE SERVE. IF CONFIRMED I WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN OPEN
REASONABLE FAIR MINDED DIRECTOR
DRAWING FROM MY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF LICENSING REGULATORY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE EXPERIENCE
WITH ABC. I'VE HAD THE GREAT
FORTUNE OF HOLDING LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS OF LOS ANGELES SAM
CISCO IN SACRAMENTO SO I WILL
CONTINUE TO USE A STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVE. IN MAKING POLICY
DECISIONS. FOR PARTLY I'LL
CONTINUE TO APPLY TO A. B. C.
ACT IN A FAIR REASONABLE.
IMPARTIAL MANNER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY AND I
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS- SENATOR BATES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO BEGIN WITH US TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM REPROACH JANET
YES AND I WANT TO SAY TO MR
KURODA DIRECTOR DORADO YOU COME
TO US AT LEAST TWO OF THE FOUR
MEMBER OF. THE RULES COMMITTEE
LIFT OFF FROM VERY GOOD
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE MANNER
IN WHICH YOU HAVE CARRY OUT
YOUR DUTIES DURING THAT. TIME
DOWNEY- PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
APPROACH WITH US- EDUCATION AND
VOLUNTARY COMPLIANCE I APPROVED
FROM NOT CERTAINLY ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF MY CONSTITUENCY
CERTAINLY THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
RESTAURANT IN THE HANDLEBAR
BUSINESSES ABOUT TWIN THEY'VE
BEEN APPROACHED BY. INDIVIDUALS
FROM ABC I'D HAS BEEN VERY
PROFESSIONAL- AND ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT DOWN A FEW OF THEM
EXPERIENCE STUFF I THINK THAT
WAS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD
A FEW ISSUES SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I JUST LIKE TO ASK ABOUT
THE MINOR DECOY A COMPLIANCE
CHECKS BECAUSE WE DO HAVE THE
HOME DELIVERY ARE PROBABLY.
REALLY RAMPED UP DURING THE-
AND THE AMERICAN IF YOU COULD
SHARE OF YOUR- ON THE IS WE GO
FOR. AND WHAT WHAT YOU. AND ARE
PROBABLY WHAT SORT OF
INTERCEPTION MIGHT BE THERE
BEFORE- WE ACTUALLY CATCH THOSE
LITTLE GUYS THAT THEIR HOUSES
LIKE. GETTING LOSE THE
DELIVERED DIRECTLY TO THEM SO
IF YOU COULD SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS ON THAT AND HOW THAT'S
WORKED INTO WHETHER THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE. IN THE
MANNER THAT YOU'RE APPLYING IT
NOW. THANK YOU CENTER BATES-
YEAH ONE ISSUE THAT WE DID
DISCOVERED DURING THE PANDEMIC
WAS THAT I'D IDENTIFICATION AT
THE TIME OF DELIVERY FOR
ALCOHOL SERVICE- WAS NOT BEING
PROPERLY CHECKED. IN SO- WE DID
OUR FIRST OPERATION BACK IN-
APRIL AND- IT WAS VERY ALARMING
WE HAD A 79% VIOLATION RATE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND SO
THAT BECAME A PRIORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- WE CONTINUED AND
AFTER US SEVEN MORE OPERATIONS-
THE LAST OPERATION BEING IN
JANUARY WE'RE ABLE TO REDUCE
THE VIOLATION RATE TO A 17%
VIOLATION RATE. SO WE'D WE TOOK
THE MATTER VERY SERIOUSLY- WE
ARE REALLY SPENT TIME
EDUCATING. AND DOING OUTREACH
WITH THESE OTHER THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY COMPANIES AND WE
CONTINUE AND GET TO ENGAGE WITH
THESE COMPANIES- WE DISCUSS
BEST PRACTICES A DAY MADE
CHANGES ON THEIR ORDERING
PLATFORMS TO ENSURE THAT
IDENTIFICATION IS PROPERLY
CHECKED. OUT AND THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO DENY ORDERS- WHEN THAT
PERSON IS UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. WE STRIVE TO
CONTINUE TO REDUCE VIOLATION
RATE- WITH AND WE STRIVE TO
IMPROVE COMPLIANCE UNDER ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THIS AREA- DURING
AND EVEN AFTER THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AGAIN NOT
VERY IMPRESSED WITH- YOUR LONG
TERM OF SERVICE AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT HAND ON WHICH YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO IN THIS VERY
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY CHALLENGING
YEAR. THANK YOU AND I WILL BE
PREPARED TO SUPPORT YOU. GET
ENOUGH. THANK YOU SENATOR PAY
ATTENTION THANK YOU THANK YOU-
CENTER LAYER. BOB THANK YOU
FOR- A MEETING WITH ME AND LET
ME CONGRATULATE YOU ON THE FACT
THAT IT'S NOT JUST THAT YOU'RE
HERE TODAY BUT YOU WORKED YOUR
WAY UP THROUGH THE RANKS HE
JUST CAME ALL THE WAY THROUGH
INSIDE AND I THINK YOU'RE TO BE
CONGRATULATED WE AD A GREAT
TALK BY SENATOR BATES TOUCHED
ON SOMETHING I WANT TO IT
WANTED TO AND YOU DID A GOOD
JOB YOUR OPENING STATEMENT JUST
HAD TO EXPAND ON ONE THING.
THEN WHEN WE TALK TODAY- YOU
SAID THAT THE PANDEMIC
PREVENTED UP PRESENTED A FEW
SPECIAL ENFORCEMENT ISSUES ED
ARE THOUGHT TO BE GOOD IF YOU
JUST MAY BE EXPANDED ON THAT A
LITTLE. THANK YOU CENTER LAYER
OF. ONE ITEM HAS JUST MENTIONED
WAS THE DELIVERY OF ALCOHOL-
CUSTOMERS THROUGHOUT THIS THE
STATE- IN YOU KNOW- OUR
PRIORITY ALSO DURING THIS THIS
TIME HAS BEEN- TO ENSURE THAT
BUSINESSES COMPLY WITH. STATE
HEALTH ORDERS. IN SO WE'VE
TAKEN A- AN EDUCATIONAL
APPROACH SEEKING VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE. BUT WE'VE BEEN VERY
IMPRESSED- THERE'S BEEN
OVERWHELMING COMPLIANCE ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I
TYPICALLY WHEN WE GIVE A
WARNING FOR NONCOMPLIANCE RE
RETURN THE NEXT DAY OR DAY
AFTER. AND THE BUSINESSES ARE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE
OUTDOORS SO WE'VE BEEN VERY
IMPRESSED WITH THAT. I BELIEVE
OUR VIOLATION RATE IS SUMMER BE
LIKE ATTENDED ONE PERCENT. DROP
THE STATE SO WE CONTINUE TO- IT
BEING COMMUNICATIONS WITH
MEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY- MAKE
SURE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE PROVIDE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION AS- COUNTY IS.
CHANGE FROM TIER TO TIER BASED
ON THEIR ICE YOU RATES. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE THAT THEY
KNOW JUST AS WELL AS WE DO THAT
THEY NOW THAT VANCE WAS CERTAIN
TEAR THEY'VE- GONE BACK TO
THIS- A CERTAIN TEARS OF THEY
WERE. AWARE OF WHAT THE
RESTRICTIONS ARE. RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY OF. THANK YOU
SENATOR LIAR SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRETEND I JUST
HAVE A COMMENT I JUST
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT YOU
GAVE ME YESTERDAY WERE YOU ABLE
TO- TALK EXTENSIVELY ABOUT SOME
CONCERNS THAT I HAD AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU NUMBER ONE FOR
ACCEPTING THIS POSITION- BACK
IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY WHEN
YOU THINK YOU WOULD EVER. COULD
HAVE KNOWN WHAT YOU WERE GOING
TO BE AN AT FAULT AND
ESPECIALLY WITH COVERT HITTING
IN MARCH- THAT WAS VERY
COURAGEOUS OF YOU AND I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR EXPLANATION
YESTERDAY ON A BALANCED
APPROACH WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE MR
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MAN PROJECT THE- BUT I
THINK THAT TO THE DPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT JOBS. IN
CALIFORNIA CREATED BY THE
TWENTY FIRST AMENDMENT SOME
YEARS AGO- YOU HAVE THE IMPACT
OF. DEALING WITH FUNDAMENTAL
ASPECTS OF PEOPLE'S BUSINESSES
WHETHER THEY'RE A BIG COAL BIG
HOTEL OR A- BIG COMPANY THAT
THE BIG RESTAURANT OR SOMETHING
AS WELL AS SMALL MOM AND POP
SHOPS. AND I JUST THINK THAT
MONEY COMMENT A LITTLE BIT ON
THIS- OF YOUR NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND LICENSEES THAT YOU
HAVE MANY OF THEM ARE. SMALL
SHOPS AND SMALL RESTAURANTS.
AND I'M JUST DEEPLY CONCERNED
ALWAYS ABOUT THE INTER
RELATIONSHIP AND HOW GOVERNMENT
TREATS PEOPLE WITH A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHOEVER THEY
MAY BE IN THE AND THAT THAT THE
INTERFACE. BETWEEN YOUR OFFICE
AND THE TONE THAT'S SET BY YOUR
INVESTIGATORS AND OR OTHER
OFFICERS- IS ALWAYS IN THE MOST
POSITIVE WAY POSSIBLE SO WANTED
TO. GO TO GET YOUR INSIGHTS AND
THOUGHT YOU MIGHT WANT TO SHARE
WITH US ON IN IN THAT REGARD-
ON. A GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF
YOUR OFFICE. THANK YOU CENTER
UP YEAH YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
IS VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT BUSINESS OWNERS
HAVE- HOW TO FACE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC- WE REALIZE THAT IT'S
BEEN A DIFFICULT TIME FOR THEM
FINANCIALLY REALIZE THAT
LIVELIHOODS ARE AT STAKE. WE
REALIZE THAT JOBS ARE AT STAKE
AND SO- THIS PANDEMIC OBVIOUSLY
BROUGHT A VERY UNIQUE SER SAID
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ABC. AND
WE'VE- AS YOU MENTIONED HAD THE
IMPORTANT TASK OF BALANCING AND
HITTING THE RIGHT THE RIGHT
BALANCE. IN SO IT'S BALANCING
BUSINESS NEEDS IN THE ECONOMY
BUT ALSO- PROTECTING THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF- CALIFORNIA'S BY
HELPING REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS AND SO. FROMTHE VERY
BEGINNING WE WE'VE TAKEN A
BUSINESS FRIENDLY EDUCATIONAL
APPROACH AGAIN- OF. THE
HOUSEHOLD ORDERS CHANGE OVER
THE MONTHS AND WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT LICENSEES ARE
AWARE OF THE CHANGES. AND ALL
OF OUR OUR STAFF HAD BEEN
TRAINED. TO DEAL WITH THIS
PANDEMIC AND REALLY SYMPATHIZE
WITH THE INDUSTRY- AS AS TIMES
CHANGE AND HELP ORDERS CHANGE
AND JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
A HEALTHY COMPLIANCE LEVEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WE'VE
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE MADE IT-
URGENT PRIORITY DO- GET OUR
TELEWORK POLICY DOWN PAT SO.
ALL TWENTY FOUR OF OUR FIELD
OFFICERS FOR STAFFED AT THE
PUBLIC COUNTER. ROTATION AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THAT WERE THERE
AT THE PUBLIC COUNTER THE
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT WERE
THERE TO ANSWER PHONES AND
EMAILS. AND TO REALLY HELP ALL
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS IT DURING
THIS TIME- BUT ALSO A TO BE
SYMPATHETIC WITH THE INDUSTRY
THAT HAS GONE THROUGH. SOME
ROUGH TIMES TO THIS AND THEN
YOUR LAST IN THAT REGARD CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOUR- ONLINE APPLICATION
PROCESS WHICH I THINK SOUNDS
PRETTY GOOD. IN TERMS OF
REDUCING THE DIFFICULTY OF
PEOPLE INTERFACE WITH THEIR
GOVERNMENT. AND TRYING TO MAKE
THE PROCESS AS EASY AS.
POSSIBLE CAN YOU GIVE US SOME
INSIGHTS INTO. YES THANK YOU SO
THE BY AFTER TWENTY NINE ACTS.
UP US A FOR YOU PLAN. TO REALLY
STRANGE THE MODERN. OUR OUR IT
TECHNOLOGY- THE PLAN IS TO- BE
ABLE DO ALCOHOL LICENSEES BILL
THE FATHER FILED THEIR
APPLICATIONS ONLINE- TO DO
LICENSE RENEWALS ONLINE AND TO
MAKE ONLINE PAYMENTS ALSO THE
ROLLOUT ARE RESPONSIBLE
BEVERAGE SERVICE PROGRAM-
WHICH- IS DUE SHORTLY AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEGAN WE WILL OPEN UP
THAT. SERVICE TO ALL LOCAL
SERVERS BY MARCH TWENTY SECOND
SO WE'RE MOVING ALONG I'M NOT
REGARD. WERE VERY FORTUNATE
GIVEN- THE FOR YOUR PLAN AND
THAT'S BEEN A PRIORITY OF OURS
IS TO REALLY- MODERNIZE OUR
OUR- TECHNOLOGY I REMAIN
TECHNOLOGICALLY AGILE ARE TO BE
MORE RESPONSIBLE LICENSEES AND
LYFT TRYING TO GROW AND YOU
THINK YOU CAN MEET YOUR
DEADLINE- YES. WE'VE- OUT
WORKING WELL WITH OUR OUR- OUR
CONTRACTOR. IN RBS PROGRAM IS
ON TIME IS ACTUALLY A BIT
EARLY- LICENSEES DON'T NEED TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE UNTIL JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE'RE
READY- WHY I'M SORRY ALCOHOL
SERVES GOOD ACTUALLY- SIGN UP
FOR TRAINING AND TO TAKE THEIR
EXAMS- BEGINNING IN MARCH SO-
WITH REGARD RBS PROGRAMMER
RIGHT THERE ARE ACTUALLY A
LITTLE AHEAD OF SCHEDULE. IN
REGARDING THE- ONLINE
CAPABILITIES WERE ABLE TO- ALL
THE FUNCTIONALITIES THAT WERE
ABLE TO DEVELOP DURING RBS
PROGRAM WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO TRANSFER OVER TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT E. SERVICES THAT I
EXPLAINED. SO WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT- SCREAMING THAT DONE-
THIS SUMMER WILL BE ABLE TO DO.
A STEP ONLINE PAYMENTS AND
ACTED IN THE YEAR WILL BE ABLE
TO A STEP ONLINE APPLICATION
TRAFFIC THANKS SO MUCH. THE YOU
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER I ONLY
HAVE ONE QUESTION- IN TERMS OF.
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO ON
REGULATORY RELIEF MEASURES
IMPLEMENTED DURING THE
PANDEMIC- DO YOU SEE
FLEXIBILITY IS ARE THINGS THAT
CAN CONTINUE GOING FORWARD THAT
YOU THINK WOULD BENEFIT AND-
NOW THAT WE'RE USED TO SOME OF
THESE PROBABLY CHANGES. I WOULD
THEY BE THINGS THAT WE COULD
IMPLEMENT GOING FORWARD THAT
WOULD SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THAT COMMUNITIES REALLY
LIKE ANY COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS
ON THAT. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- TO THE BIG REGULATORY
RELIEF ITEMS THAT WE RECEIVED-
WATER PRAISED FROM THE INDUSTRY
HAVE BEEN ALLOWING ALCOHOL
DELIVERY AS WELL AS- EXPANDING
OUTDOOR DINING- DURING THE TIME
WHEN. OUTDOOR DOT ORG EDITOR
DURING THE TIME WHEN INDOOR
DYING WAS PROHIBITED SO I KNOW
THERE ARE ARE TWO BILLS RIGHT
NOW. THE LEGISLATURE IN SO- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WILLING TO BE WHAT
THE AUTHORS AND OFFER ANY
TECHNICAL- ASSISTANCE ON THAT.
AND AS FAR AS LIKE LIFTING
OTHER TYPE OF REGULATORY RELIEF
MEASURES WILL WILL CAREFULLY
ORCHESTRATE THAT WITH- ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL
AS A DEMONSTRATION TO MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE. WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH DIRECTOR
PARTICULARLY I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES ASK ABOUT THE
DELIVERY BUT IN PARTICULAR THE
OUTDOOR EXPANSION AND I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN AN ISSUE SOME
COMMUNITIES OF LOOKED AT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND OF COURSE
WE WERE ALWAYS PRETTY RIGID.
AND HE UNDERSTANDABLY SO-
COMMUNITIES REACT- IT IS THAT
BALANCING ACT THAT I THINK YOU
ACTUALLY I WOULD AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU DO SO WELL-
THAT I APPRECIATE BUT OUT ONCE
YOU KNOW ACROSS A CRISIS IN A
PANDEMIC DIMMICK HAVE OPENED
UP. OTHER OPTIONS THAT WE'VE
NOW BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO THAT
MAY SEEM MORE- PALATABLE THAN
DID BEFORE SO I THINK FROM WHAT
I'VE NOTICED. I DRIVING AROUND
COMMUNITIES HAVE REALLY ENJOYED
THAT ASPECT AND I KNOW THERE
ARE OBVIOUSLY ISSUES AROUND IT
BUT- BUT I SEEM TO BE A
POSITIVE PART OF A PRETTY
NEGATIVE IN DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY YOUR- OPENNESS
SEVEN I AGREE. WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- IN TERMS OF THEIR
ASSETS ASSESSMENTS OF YOUR TAKE
IN THE- THE RAIDS AT ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL. AT THIS POINT
IF THERE ARE NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FURTHER FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND
WE'LL START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. FIVE AND
I. SEEING NO ONE N. THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I WILL LOOK AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE THAT IS OUR SECOND
ROOM TO SEE IF THEIR WITNESSES
I DO NOT SEE ANYONE APPROACHING
THE PODIUM. SO WE WILL GO TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE I AND I WILL
WELCOME AND INTRODUCE OUR
MODERATOR TO SEE IF YOU CAN
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF DIRECTOR-
HARADA AND WILL BEGIN WELCOME.
MODERATOR WHAT THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN SUPPORT. OUR FIRST LINE
WILL COME FROM LINE TWENTY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS FRANK EDWIN AND CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN HEAR YOU I'M
SORRY TO INTERRUPT GO AHEAD. NO
WORRIES NO WORRIES MY NAME IS
WINTER ONE TIME ADMINISTRATOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA FRIDAY NIGHT
LIFE PARTNERSHIP. I'M EXTREMELY
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
VOICE MY ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT
OF THE APPOINTMENT OF MR ERA
CURRENT PRODUCTS TO THE
POSITION OF DIRECTOR OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL. I
AM OF THE GREATEST CONVICTION
THAT MR REID IS AN OUTSTANDING
CHOICE FOR THIS ROLE. WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE CALIFORNIA
WITH INTEGRITY VISION AND HIS
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT THAT I'VE
COME TO EXPECT FROM HIM. HE HAS
DEDICATED HIS ENTIRE CAREER TO
WORK OF ABC AND AS A RESULT IS
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL EQUIPPED TO
LEAD THE AGENCY IN THIS MOST
CHALLENGING OF TIMES. I COME TO
YOU TODAY WITH WHAT I BELIEVE
IN THE UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE AND
POINT OF REPRESENTATION IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH MR HARADA. I
HAVE WORKED WITH HIM IN MY ROLE
AS THE ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
STATE WIDE STATE FUNDED FRIDAY
NIGHT LIKE PROGRAM. AS A CAREER
PROFESSIONAL IN THE FIELD OF
PREVENTION AND IS A COMMUNITY
MEMBER LOOKING. TO A. B. C. FOR
CHANGE IN A TIME OF TRAGEDY. I
THE PREVENTION. I'VE FOCUSED ON
AND DRINKING PREVENTION
STRATEGIES FOR THE WHOLE OF MY
CAREER. IN TRYING TO CHANGE THE
COMPUTING COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTS. THAT WERE
INFLUENCING THIRTEEN YEAR OLD
CHILDREN TO USE ALCOHOL I
LEARNED ABOUT THE CRITICAL ROLE
THE ABC PLAYS IN THE WELL BEING
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. ON THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THEM.
WELL ABC IS CHARGED WITH THE
OVERSIGHT AND YES SUPPORT OF
ALCOHOL COMMERCE IN THE STATE.
IT ALSO HAS A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN THE PREVENTION OF UNDERAGE
AND PROBLEM ALCOHOL
CONSUMPTION. MR HADA BALANCES
BOTH ASPECTS VERY WELL. AS A
MEMBER OF SEVERAL STATEWIDE
PREVENTION BOARD AND COALITIONS
I WORKED WITH MR HER ON VARIOUS
ISSUES. IN THIS PANDEMIC AS
ACTING DIRECTOR MR HARADA HAVE
INHERITED SOME RELAXED ABC
REGULATIONS. THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
FAVORED BY THE PREVENTION
COMMUNITY. MAKING HIM UNPOPULAR
BY ITS TITLE ALONE. EVERY
MEETING OCCASION I'VE
EXPERIENCED MISTER ROGERS OPEN
RESPONSIVE AND PROFESSIONAL.
HE'S ADDRESS OPPOSITION WITH
GRAYSON RESPECT WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN HIM WINNING THE
REGARD. AS MANY CHALLENGING
CONSTITUENT. FOR MY PER. AS A
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY A MOTHER I
WORKED WITH MR HARADA IN ABC
BROWN THIS WELL. AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD DRINKING DRIVER KILLED
MY DAUGHTER. AFTER THE LOSS OF
CASEY I WORKED WITH ABC AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY MISTER RADHA.
TO CREATE A POLICY THAT WOULD
TRACE THE SOURCE OF ALCOHOL
CONSUMED BY AN UNDERAGE
DRINKING DRINKER INVOLVED IN
THE TRAGEDY. AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE ADULT WHO
PROVIDED IT. MR HARADA
UNDERSTAND VERY INSTINCTIVELY I
BELIEVE THE COMMUNITY
PREVENTION PRINCIPLES THAT
IMPACT ALL OF OUR LIVES. AS A
RESULT MR HARADA REALIZE ABC
HAD BOTH THE POWER AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TRACE THE
SOURCE OF ALCOHOL ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY. HE'S BEEN KEY
IN MOVING TRACE FORWARD AS
POLICY THAT HAS NOW BEEN
REPLICATED IN OVER THIRTY
STATES. AS WELL AS NOW BEING A
FULL BLOWN DEPARTMENT WITHIN
ABC. I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
WELL BEING OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ERICA REID HAS THE
EXPERIENCE THE COMMITMENT AND
INTEGRITY WE NEED TO LEE HELPED
LEAD OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGH
THE CHALLENGES BROUGHT ABOUT BY
THIS PANDEMIC. AND MOVE US
FORWARD STEP WITH VISION AND
PARTNERSHIP. IS WITH COMPLETE
AND TOTAL CONFIDENCE. THAT I'M
HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT MR HER
KERALA AS DIRECTOR OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MADAME MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU KNOW
COMPLAIN OF EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WHEN MADAM CHAIR DEL BARCELONA
TREASURES THE BARGAINING UNIT
SEVEN CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION. JUST
CALLING TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE'RE FULL SUPPORT OF
DISAPPOINTMENT- UNIT SEVEN HAS.
ALL BE ENFORCEMENT AGENTS AND
INSPECTORS WITH THEIR AT THE
APARTMENT AND- THEY HAVE THE
UTMOST OF RESPECT TO HIM AND IT
LOOKED AT HIM WITH AND YOU THEM
FOR YEARS. AND THEY- THEY ALL
ARE BUSY ASPECT. ABOUT ZERO
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MATTER MODERATE
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU LETTER
COME FROM LINE OF SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS STEVEN TEN LAPS IN AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC STATE EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION APPS THE APPS THAT
YOU THE PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION THAT IS DEDICATED
TO EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
ADVANCEMENT OR ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS EMPLOYED. I'M SHOULD
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF AB C. TO
OFFER SUPPORT BUT BETTER
EDUCATION ABOUT. HEY I THANK
THE RECOGNIZED LEADER WITHIN
STATE GOVERNMENT WILL BE TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OF. SERVICE AND
TWENTY FIVE OF THOSE YEARS IN
SERVICE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL.
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT MAKE IT
A GOOD AN EXCEPTIONALLY
QUALIFIED AND REMINDED
CANDIDATES TO SERVE AS DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL. YOU CAN HAVE
THE DISTINCTION OF BEING THE
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN DEPUTY
DIVISION CHIEF. DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL.
RULES WHICH IS WORK ETHIC
INTELLECT AND LEADERSHIP
ABILITIES. BE TESTED AND-
NEEDLESS TO SAY EVERY COUPLE
REST LEADER IN THE COMMUNITY.
OUTSIDE WORK THE SERVICE ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. AFTER THE
PROBATION. AT A QUITE CITY PUT
NUMBER. HE IS ALSO INVOLVED IN
OTHER APPLICATIONS LIKE APPS.
WHERE HE CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
PTI COMMUNITY AND THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CIVIL SERVANT
LEADERS. HAPPY SUPPORT THE
APPOINT AND COMPANIES ALL ERIC
OUT TO HAVE ABOUT DEEP OF
ALCOHOL PRODUCTS. ABSOLUTELY IS
THE BEST CANDIDATE TO SERVE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THIS CRITICAL
POSITION. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU IT'LL
COME FROM LINE OF THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SH. ONE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN BOB SHARK
BANNER CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IS TO DISMANTLE
ESPINOZA WHETHER ONE IS FOR A
FULL SET OF X. CALIFORNIA- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY DOCTOR COMMENTS
FOLLOW ON ALL BUT. ONE DIRECTOR
HARISH. AFTER SHIFTED WE
BELIEVE. OUR THE NEW SO COULD
NOT MADE A BETTER. TO LEAD.
BAKULA GREAT RESPECT. WE WILL
RESULT NATIONAL YEARS WE'VE HAD
THE OPTION TO WITH HIM ON
VARIOUS- SO COULD WORK FOR
TRUMP IN WAS EVER FROM THE-
THERE IS A PERSON- QUESTION
CHARACTER. AND BUT- THE- IT A
HIGH LEVEL OF USE THAT ALL OUR
OF THE HOW DID. UNDER THE
PARTNERSHIP. LOS. THAT
EXPERIENCE IT OTHER OF THE
INDUSTRY ALSO IT WOULDN'T THE
QUICK- RELEASED HERE TO SET UP
OKAY OTHER. HOW THEY HAVE
HANDLED. THAT ALISTAIR A
STUDENT NOT IN THIS ISSUE AS
PART IN. WE HAVE AN OVER THE
RATES AT THE PEOPLE TO SAY WILL
BE SERVED. BY HIS LEADERSHIP OF
THE APC WE STRONGLY ASK YOUR
FAVORITE BILL CONSIDERING. OF
THIS FROM. THANK NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU BETTER COME FROM LINE
OF NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JEFF MCKAY AND I'M A JOINT
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL. I'M
ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF CAL COACH
CALIFORNIA CALLED THERE'S
CONTROL AGENTS ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS AN AFFILIATE OF
DETAILING I'M CALLING TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT- ACROSS AS DIRECTOR
NEVER MY TWENTY SIX YEAR THE
STATE SERVICE I'VE EVER HAD A
LEADER WHO'D BEEN SO FOCUSED ON
THE ADVANCEMENT OF THEIR
DEPARTMENT AND ALL OF ITS
EMPLOYEES. THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATION MR A- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU AND THAT'LL COME FROM
LINE OF THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LORI AJAX AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. THE
STATION WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH DIRECTOR HARADA AND HIS
TEAM AT THE CALIFORNIA EIGHTY
THREE. I HAVE PERSONALLY KNOWN
DIRECTOR HARADA FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HIM AT
THE ABC HE'S A TREMENDOUS
LEADER WHO LEADS WITH INTEGRITY
EXPERIENCE AND COMPASSION. AND
THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION FULLY SUPPORTS HIS
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
AND THAT WAS OUR LAST ONE IN-
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT MANAGER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER
MODERATOR WE WILL BE BACK WITH
YOU IN A FEW MOMENTS. SO WE
WILL BEGIN BY WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM. WITNESSES WHO MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE APPOINTMENT
AND WE WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS. SO WE WILL START WITH-
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I STILL SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE TO
SPEAK. I WILL AGAIN LOOK AT AYE
AYE A ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO
ONE APPROACHES THE PODIUM. SO
MADAM MODERATOR I'M COMING BACK
TO YOU NOW FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE APPOINTMENT. IF YOU WERE
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MATTER MODERATOR I WILL
BRING IT BACK INTO THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND SEE IF
THERE IS A MOTION. MADAM
SECRETARY- MISS GROWTH SENATOR
GROWTH I THINK TO BEAT THE
OTHERS TO THE PUNCH HERE WITH
THAT MOTION SO. WHAT'S THAT.
WANT TO DO IT. YES IT'S A GOOD
SIGN I WILL SAY- I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES WHO SAID EARLIER.
OBVIOUSLY YOU COME WITH
INCREDIBLE ART REFERENCES
RECOMMENDATIONS AND OBVIOUSLY
THE SPEAKERS BORE THAT OUT SO
IT'S NO SMALL TASK THAT THREE
PEOPLE TRY TO GET ON THE MIKE.
I TO MAKE THE MOTION SO- MADAM.
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. GROVE FIVE ROW FIVE
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG FIVE
LAYERED HI I BATES HI IT'S AYE
ATKINS HI CAN FIVE FIVE IT IS
UNANIMOUS SAID LET US THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR
CONGRADULATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THIS INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY LET
ME LOOK- IS IT GOOD TO CONTINUE
LET ME JUST. SURE YOU CAN
CONTINUE NK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WE WILL GO TO ITEM ONE B.
WHICH IS THE APPOINTMENT OF
JOSEPH WILLIAMS MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. AND LET ME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND SAY
WELCOME TO YOU MISTER WILLIAMS.
LET ME INVITE YOU- TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS STATEMENTS-
FEEL FREE TO INTRODUCE OUR
KNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
TO THAT'S BEEN SUPPORTIVE. AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY. ALL
MY NAME IS JOSEPH ARE WILLIAMS-
I'VE SERVED UNDER THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION OR THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. AND ARE
REPRESENTED AT BOARD ON THE
CALIFORNIA COULD. LIMIT OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES- AS
YOU KNOW GOVERNOR NEWSOM
APPOINTED ME TO SERVE ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO BOTH HE AND
GOVERNOR BROWN FOR PUTTING
THEIR TRUST IN ME TO SERVE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FIRST AND
FOREMOST- I'M HUSBAND I'M A
FATHER AND- WE TEASE WE'RE WE
HAVE TWO ADULT TRIMS AS WE HAVE
TWO OLDER- ADULTS REALLY. AND
HOW TO CHILDREN AND- TWO
GRANDSONS- I PROMOTE MYSELF AS
A PRODUCT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM I SPENT TEN
YEARS. TAKING CLASSES AT THREE
DIFFERENT COLLEGES BEFORE
TRANSFERRING OUT WITH MY- FIFTY
FIVE UNITS NEVER. RECEIVED AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE BUT I DID
EARN A BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS. AND
ALSO EARNED A MASTER'S IN
SOCIAL IMPACT FROM CLAREMONT
LINCOLN UNIVERSITY- COMPASSION
ABOUT THIS ROLE BECAUSE I
WANTED STUDENTS OR HOW WILL I
DON'T WANT STUDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE. SOME OF THE- WHAT I
CALL THE DEFICITS OF THE SYSTEM
BUT I DO WANT TO ASSIST IN
SCALING UP. THE POSITIVE THINGS
THAT HELP ME GET THROUGH THE
SYSTEM AND TO THE PLACE THAT I
FIND MYSELF TODAY. AND I WOULD
USE MY MIND MY EXPERTISE AS A
FORMER STUDENT. I SERVED AS A
STUDENT TRUSTEE- EXAM AGAIN
COLLEGE AND ALSO ARE CURRENTLY
SEATED TRUSTEE OF A MULTI
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND WHAT I'M
INTERESTED IN INITIALLY IS
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THAT I WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN THE SAN
BERNARDINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO SECURE. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THE INLAND
EMPIRE FREE COLLEGE PROMISE.
WHERE THREE THOUSAND LOCAL HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS HAVE INCREASED
ACCESS TO COLLEGE AND I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THAT PROGRAM.
I'M ALSO INTERESTED IN REDUCING
THE EXCESS UNITS THAT STUDENT
STATE AND YOU KNOW BEEN SORT OF
A STRONG SUPPORTER. OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE PADDOCK
PATHWAYS. WE'RE THE IS THE
OTHER THAT I'M CLEAN KEY WE CAN.
IN SUPPORT CLASS. WITH LOCAL
AND STATE WORK TO BOARD.
LOOKING AT WHERE TO REDUCE
UNNECESSARY DUPLICATION OF
SERVICES AND LEVERAGE THE
ASSETS THAT WE HAVE BETWEEN
BOTH OF THE SYSTEMS. ARE I WANT
TO THANK MY FAMILY WHO IS ALL
WATCHING VIA LIVESTREAM MY UP
MY MOM. MOM MOM AND DAD A
LITTLE OF BOTH WATCHING. MY
WIFE A TEACHER WILLIAMS IS HERE
WATCHING MY TWO YEAR OLD
DAUGHTERS AYLA AND MY ONE YEAR
I MEAN MY FOUR YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER IS A LET LET ME GET
THAT RIGHT. AND MY TWO YEAR
OLD. SIETE I HAVE A TWENTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD. AND A TWENTY
THREE YEAR OLD JOSEPH AND MY
TWO GRAND SLAM JUNIOR TYLER-
AND THEN THE HOSTESS SUPPORTERS
THAT ARE ARE WATCHING- THANK
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU ASK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
MISTER LEADER I WILL START ON
YOUR END OF THE DYESS THIS TIME.
HEY JOHN. I'M GOOD GOOD HOW ARE
YOU SIR I'M GOOD. I AGES GET A
VERY GOOD CONVERSATION AND
INTERVIEWING PRIOR TO THIS-
COMMITTEE HEARING AND I KNOW
THE STAFF AND OTHERS VERY
IMPRESSED BY YOUR COMMITMENT
AND CREATIVITY AND IMAGINATION.
ON WHAT I DEEM TO BE A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT JOB AT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN NOW-
COMMITTEE COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA AND- THEY MENTIONED
NOT ONLY DO WE ARE THESE PLACES
WERE- INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT THE
AVERAGE AGE OF BELIEVES TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS BECOME A
CRITICAL ELEMENT OF THE-
CONSIDERED LEARNING. APPROACH
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX SOCIETY IN
WHICH WE- HAVEN'T SO MANY NEW
JOBS AND SKILLS. ARE BEING
ENGAGED I JUST ENCOURAGE YOU-
IN OUR MEETING AND I DO SO NOW
OF PUBLICLY. TO BE INNOVATIVE
AND CREATIVE IN AN AREA OF
PUBLIC POLICY THAT I THINK IS
SO ESSENTIAL FOR. A COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FOLKS AND- I AM VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I JUST THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
SERVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE OVER THE YEARS. AND- I-
AND- OUR OUR COMMON
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU MR
MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM- MISTER
WILLIAMS I DIDN'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRUST YOU BUT- I
AGAIN ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS ABOUT THANKING YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND- I DO HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS YOU KNOW WHAT
LESSONS HAVE BEEN LEARNED- BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT HAVE
TRANSITIONED TO REMOTE
INSTRUCTION. AND WHAT'S YOUR-
WHAT DO YOU ENVISION REGARDING
DISTANCE LEARNING GOING FORWARD.
YEAH I THINK THE LESSONS
LEARNED IS THAT YOU KNOWWE
COULD DO A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE DIDN'T FEEL LIKE WE CAN DO
BEFORE BECAUSE- WE- AND LOCALLY
WE TRANSITION. 80% OF OUR
CLASSES ONLINE IN A MATTER OF
TWO WEEKS AND WE GET A LOT OF
WE GET CRITICIZED A LOT ABOUT.
HOW SLOW WE MOVEMENT SO I THINK
ONE OF THE LESSONS LEARNINGS
THAT WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
INNOVATE WHEN- THE WILL IS
THERE TO DO SO AND I THINK YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE LESSONS
LEARNED- YOU KNOW IT IS YOU
KNOW JUST HOW ARE WE USING
TECHNOLOGY TO. ENGAGE D. THE
VARIOUS LEARNING STYLES OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
HOPING THAT THE FUTURE WILL
LOOK LIKE IS A MORE HYBRID
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
WHERE THEY GET A MIX. OF IN
PERSON AND ONLINE ENGAGEMENT.
ON YOU KNOW I'M ALSO EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY OF WHAT
DIGITAL TEXTBOOKS CAN BRING IN
TERMS OF. HOW DYNAMIC THEY CAN
BE AND HOW YOU CAN UPDATE THEM
AND CHANGE THEM ON THE FLY INTO
TESTING GOOGLE'S BOOKS. AND
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT YOU
KNOW THROUGH USING TECHNOLOGY
LIKE THAT IT ACTUALLY INCREASES
THE RETENTION OF INFORMATION ON
STUDENTS SO- YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
JUST JUST A FEW THINGS THAT- I
THINK THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR.
ONLINE LEARNING. THANK YOU SIR
VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING THAT.
SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR. A AND- MONEY
JUST- TERRY I REALLY ENJOYED
OUR MEETING THIS MORNING I
REALLY ENJOYED TALKING ABOUT
OUR COMMON SERVICE AS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRUSTEES AND ALSO HAD
REALLY ENJOYED TALKING ABOUT
OUR COMMON SERVICE WITH JOHN
LONG FAIL AND I THINK SENATOR
BATES ALSO SERVED. A HE'S ON
THE COLLEGE BOARD WITH- YOU DID
IT WELL- SO THERE'S LOTS OF
THINGS TO TAKE BACK I THINK THE
INTERESTING THING FOR MORE
CONVERSATION AND THERE WERE
MANY. IS THAT YOUR IN THIS
UNIQUE POSITION THAT YOU SERVE
SEVEN YEARS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND NOW YOU GET TO TAKE ALL THE
LESSONS OR PASSIONS TO THE
STATE LEVEL WHILE DOING BOTH
SERVICE- WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
LESSONS THAT YOU HAVE FROM-
YOUR LOCAL SERVICE ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR DO YOU
REALLY WANT TO TAKE AND PRESS.
AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL. YEAH
YOU KNOW. I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT I WHAT I LIKE TO WHICH WE
TEND TO HAVE A DEFICIT MINDSET
AND YOU KNOW FOCUS ON THE NEED
FIRST AND- WHAT I'VE LEARNED IS
THAT YOU KNOW THROUGH ASSET
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT KIND OF
APPROACH IF WE LOOK AT WHAT IS
GOING. WELL AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING BECAUSE THERE THERE'S
ALWAYS THESE POCKETS OF
EXCELLENCE THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN
IDENTIFY. AND YOU KNOW DO MY
EXPERIENCE LOCALLY AND IN THE
WORK FORCE FOR WE LOOK AT IS
HOW DO WE TAKE THE ASSETS AND
WHAT THE BEST PRACTICES AND
START LOOKING AT REGIONALLY.
HOW WE CAN REPLICATE THE THINGS
THAT ARE GOING WELL AND THEN
SCALE. AND ALSO IDENTIFY IF
THERE ARE SOME GAPS BEGIN TO
CREATE PLANS TO ADDRESS THOSE
GAPS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE LOCALLY THAT I THAT
I HOPE TO BRING TO THE STATE
IS. BEING ABLE TO COLLABORATE
WITH COUNTIES AND YOU KNOW
CALFRESH IS A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
WHERE YOU KNOW WE BEGIN TO WORK
WITH YOU KNOW THE OUNTY BOARD
OF SOUPS. TO IDENTIFY WAYS TO
OPEN UP CAO FRESH TO SOME OF
OUR STUDENTS AND I THINK AT THE
STATE LEVEL. WE CAN ALSO LOOK
AT GREAT WAYS TO LEVERAGE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE DO HAVE
ACCESS TO. THE STATE AGENCIES
AND IN THE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
WORK CLOSER AND ARE MORE
STRATEGICALLY WHAT THE
CAMPUSES. AND YOU KNOW BEGIN TO
GET THE CAMPUSES TO SEE
THEMSELVES AS A PART OF THE
OVERALL SYSTEM. AND IT IT JUST
REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND NOT JUST BE
KINDA ISLANDS TO THEMSELVES AND
IN AND ASK. YOU KNOW REALLY
WHAT I'VE LEARNED FROM YOU KNOW
BEING ON THE SAN BERNARDINO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD IS THAT
IF WE REACH OUT. BREAK BREAD
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER ENTITIES
WE GOT FIVE BECAUSE WE'RE
SOMETIMES WE'RE ALL SERVING THE
SAME PEOPLE BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT TOGETHER AND
SO. HOPEFULLY BEING ABLE TO
PLACE THAT ON THE MIND OF THE
BARGAIN IN JUST DOING SOME
OUTREACH TO STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND JUST TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
TO WORK TOGETHER. IS SOMETHING
THAT I REALLY LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BRING TO THE
TABLE GRATEFUL THANK THE BOARD
OF THE LUCKY TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEAHY SENATOR
BATES. WELL LET ME ASK OF THAT
A VERY IMPRESSED- SPECIALLY
WITH YOUR GOAL. FOR YOUR TENURE
ON THIS BOARD ON MR WILLIAMS I
WAS READING THAT AND I WAS
REALLY TAKEN BY. ONE OF THE
GOALS THAT YOU SET FORTH COURSE
RELEVANCE TO SKILLS STUDENTS
WILL NEED TO SUCCEED IN THE
WORKPLACE. AND NOTING THAT THE
RECENT SURVEYS OF CORPORATE
LEADERS THAT SHE WOULD BE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH ALSO BASED ON
YOUR CLIMATE HISTORY BELIEVE
HERE COLLEGE GRAD SCHOOL HAVE
SKILLS LIKE. PROBLEM SOLVING
AND CRITICAL THINKING NEEDED TO
JOBS AND I THINK THAT SOMETHING
THAT- WE HOLD A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IT IS THE IT IS
THE STATE OF OPPORTUNITY. AND
CERTAINLY ARE- ON OUR-
ELEMENTARY ARE SECONDARY AND
COLLEGE EDUCATION IS VITAL TO-
BEING ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
DREAM SO WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF HOW COURSES
CAN BE STRUCTURED TO KIND OF
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. IT IS ONE
OF YOUR GOALS AND I'M SURE THAT
YOU'VE HAD A LOT OF THINKING
ABOUT. WHAT SHE WOULD BRING
FORWARD IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS THAT YOU SERVE ON THIS
BOARD. VERY VERY INTERESTING
BECAUSE IT IS FUNDAMENTAL I
THINK WE GO TO COLLEGE- TO
LEARN THE PROBLEM SOLVING THAT
CERTAINLY WHAT FACES ALL OF US
AT EVERY LEVEL OF OUR SOCIETY
NOW. THOSE SHARE SOME THOUGHTS
ON THAT WITH ME AND OF I'M VERY
IMPRESSED. YEAH THERE'S A
FRAMEWORK THAT I'VE BEEN
STUDYING CALL TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
LEARNING SKILLS AND- YOU KNOW
IT IS ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT AND- I
THINK THE FIRST THE FIRST PART
IS BUILDING. TRUSTEE CAPACITY
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLE
AND THEIR AUTHORITY BECAUSE WE
TEND TO STAY OUT OF CURRICULA.
AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE IT'S A TEN
PLUS ONE ISSUE AND BUT STATE
LAW DOES GIVE. THE TRUSTEES THE
ABILITY TO BRING ABOUT-
SPECIFIC PROGRAMMING AND YOU
KNOW THEY'VE IT JUST SAYS NO WE
HAVE TO- COLLEGIATELY CONSULT
WITH OUR ACADEMIC SENATES AND
YOU KNOW. BRING THEM IN INTO
THE CONVERSATION AND MAKE SURE
THAT. THEY'RE THEY'RE OF ALL
THIS SO I THINK THAT FIRST PART
IS MAKING SURE THE TRUSTEES DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY DO HAVE A
ROLE. IN MAKING SURE BECAUSE
THEY ARE ELECTED TO KNOW WHAT
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY NEEDS AND
SELL WHAT I HEAR FROM EMPLOYERS
ALL THE TIME IS THAT. YOU KNOW
YOU GUYS ARE NOT GETTING ANY
YOU DON'T DEVELOP CURRICULUM
FAST ENOUGH. AND YOU'RE NOT
FOCUSED ON THE SKILLS THAT- WE
MEET YOU KNOW FOR INSTANCE MY
DISTRICT IS BUILDING. A NINETY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR- CAREER
TECH CENTER IN IS A NET ZERO
BUILDING. YES WE DON'T HAVE
ENERGY RELATED CURRICULUM-
PLANET SO I'VE BEEN PRESSING TO
SAY THAT LOOK. WE'RE GONNA
SPEND ALL THESE EXTRA MONEY
BUILDING THESE ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES IT'S GOT A SHOP IN
THE CURRICULUM THE CPUC. IS
TALKING ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION IS
TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW HOW WE
GET THESE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
THEY'RE GRAPPLING WITH THIS
WHOLE IDEA OF ADAPTIVE CAPACITY
AND HOW. COMMUNITIES ARE ARE
ABLE TO ADAPT AND EVOLVE WITH
THE CHANGING ENVIRONMENT. THIS
IS ONE WAY THAT WE CAN DO THAT
MAKE SURE THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THESE ADVANCED
BUILDINGS WE'RE TEACHING THE
STUDENTS ABOUT. HOW THEY WERE
IN ALL THE DIFFERENT CAREER
PATHS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
IT AND SO. I THINK YOU KNOW AT
THE STATE LEVEL WAS PUSHING A
DIALOGUE. I WAS REALLY. IN DOWN
AND TALKING. THE LARGEST. SIZE
AND YEARS AND REALLY. GET A
BASELINE OF WHAT IS IT THAT YOU
ALL OF LOOKING FOR. A
CALIBRATED IS YOU KNOW WHAT
COMPANY BASED. ON AGE. MODEL WE
CAN LEARN SOMETHING FROM BACK
THAT COULD BE APPLIED IN THE
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS TO REALLY.
YOU KNOW FOCUS ON CORE SKILLS
LIKE COMMUNICATION SKILLS
FINANCIAL ALL OF THE BASIC
SKILLS THAT YOU DON'T REALLY
LEARN. IN K. TWELVE AND YOU
KNOW EVEN IN OUR SYSTEM I THINK
SO PRICE IN A CONVERSATION WITH
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS. I'LL
MAKE SURE THAT WE YOU KNOW
BUILD OUR CAPACITY TO JUST
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE- THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE WITH
SOME OF THESE THESE THESE
ISSUES IS WHAT I REALLY. YOU
KNOW AIM TO DO IS TALK ABOUT IT
A LOT AND GRAIN YOU KNOW THESE
FOLKS TO THE TABLE. AND KIND.
OF LEARN AND DEVELOP THE
SOLUTIONS TOGETHER. OKAY YOU
FOR THE RESPONSE AND PROBABLY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE LEVELS BEYOND JUST. THE
EDUCATIONAL AROUND YOU'VE BEEN
VERY INVOLVED IN PHILANTHROPY
ALSO- VERY IMPRESSIVE GOALS
AND- WHERE ARE LEGISLATURE CAN
HELP YOU IN ACHIEVING THEY'LL
FURTHER. THEIR VERY SIGNIFICANT
SO YOU NEED TO CALL ENOUGH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
SENATOR BASS ARE. AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THOSE-
VERY THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO%
WILL TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND AS
WE DO THAT I WANT TO DO A
REMINDER AT THIS POINT. FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
COMMENT VIA PHONE THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
I'M GOING TO MENTION AGAIN IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. SO WE WILL
START WITH THE WITNESSES IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THERE ARE STILL NO. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THIS ROOM TO
TESTIFY. I WILL LOOK AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE. I STILL SEE NO ONE
APPROACH TO THE DICE TO SPEAK
SO MADAM MODERATOR I'M GOING TO
COME BACK TO YOU. WITH A
REMINDER OF TWO PEOPLE WHO
SPEAK TO US. LIST YOUR NAME IN
THE ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT BE
AFFILIATED WITH AND YOUR
COMMENTS SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY SO WE CAN MAKE SURE OUR
STENOGRAPHER IS ABLE TO GET.
YOUR TESTIMONY AND WITH THAT
MADAME MODERATOR WILL YOU LET
US KNOW. WHO IS TEED UP TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF MISTER
WILLIAMS. YES THANK YOU OF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT
NUMBER ONE WILL COME FROM LINE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAN YOU
HEAR ME MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE YES WE CAN THANK YOU.
GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS COLUMN ALL RIGHT WE
COULD STERILE I'M A STUDENT AT
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE
WRAPPING UP. MY LAST SEMESTER
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS I'VE
WORKED TIRELESSLY AND ADVOCACY
ROLES TO MAKE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MORE STUDENT FOCUSED.
INCLUDING SERVING IN MY LOCAL
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. FOR THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND AS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. I SAID. WE'RE TRULY
BEFORE YOU TODAY BELIEVING
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT THE
CONFIRMATION OF MR JOSEPH
WILLIAMS IS A GUARANTEED WAY TO
MAKE THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS AND
US THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MORE STUDENT FOCUSED.
MR WILLIAMS HAS JOINED THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS HE HAS BEEN
AN ALLY OF THE STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE. REACHING OUT AT
HIS VERY FIRST MEETING HE
SHARED WITH THE BOARD STUDENT
MEMBERS. LOOK FOR A WEEKEND
PASS MISTER WILLIAMS SOUGHT OUT
THE STUDENT PERSPECTIVE ON
ISSUES LIKE TEXTBOOK
AFFORDABILITY. AND SINCE HAS
SHOWN AN UNWAVERING COMMITMENT
TO SERVING THE STUDENTS OF THE
SYSTEM. IT IS NO SECRET THAT ON
MANY ISSUES TRUSTEES AND
STUDENTS DISAGREE COULD NOT
WITH TRUSTEES LIKE MR WILLIAMS.
MR WILLIAMS IS THE
QUINTESSENTIAL TRUST THE- ONE
WHO AFFECTED REALLY BALANCES
THE NEEDS OF THE CONSTITUENTS
OF HIS DISTRICT. WITH THE NEEDS
OF THE STUDENTS OF HIS
DISTRICT. HE IS EXTREMELY
STUDENT FOCUSED PRECISELY
BECAUSE HE HAS LIVED AT THE
CHALLENGES OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. THE
TRUTH IS THE BEST A TRUSTEES
LIKE MR WILLIAMS UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ONLY REASON THAT MAKES
IT IN THE RESPECTIVE POSITIONS
OF POWER. I'VE SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS. MISTER WILLIAMS
BELIEVES AS I BELIEVE AS ALL
STUDENTS BELIEVE. THAT THE
WIDER WE OPENTHE DOORS OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHETHER BY
DECREASING TEXTBOOK COSTS FOR
FIXING OUR BROKEN FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM THE GREATER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA. TO
SEE THE DOORMAT POTENTIAL THAT
LAY BURIED IN TOO MANY OF OUR
CITIZENS. MASON MIND I ASK ON
BEHALF OF ALL STUDENTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY. ON BEHALF
OF ALL THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
TEETER ON THE EDGE OF PURSUING
THEIR DREAMS BUT LOOKING AT THE
STATUS QUO THE SIDE OTHERWISE.
THOSE PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS THE
FUTURE OF THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ALL MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE VOTING TO THE
OPTICALLY TO CONFIRM THE
APPOINTMENT OF MR JUSTICE
WILLIAMS AS A MEMBER. OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS STUDENTS CAN
AFFORD NO LESS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN AFFORD NO LESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM. MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK LETTER COME FROM
WIND TWENTY FOUR YEAR ONE IS
OPEN. HELLO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN YOU GIVE ME YES I
CAN'T THANK YOU. GREAT HI MY
NAME IS MICHAEL WE OPERATE HERE
IT HAD TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A
TRUSTEE OF THE WILLIAM I'M A
STUDENT LEADER- FORMALLY
PRESIDENT OF THE TOPIC THE
MEDICATION. ACTUALLY REPRESENT
A CRITICAL THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I AM A MEMBER OF
DIED RECENTLY. AT LEAST REPORT-
OF COURSE EVERYTHING READY FOR.
I CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
WHAT KIND. WHAT TO READ READ
YOU IT SAN DIEGO STATE. IN AND
I HAD GRADUATED CURRENT
GRADUATE IN INDUSTRY I USED
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF POLICY. I'M
INTERESTED WILLIAM BE MUST
DEVELOP WEEKENDS CONNECT ABOUT
TO BETTER FOR STUDENTS TO TODAY
NOT ONLY GROW WITH US DOLLARS
IN PERTH BUT AS DOOR DIVERSITY.
AFTER GRAPPLE WITH THAT BASE
AND OUR COMMUNITY IT'S CLEAR
THAT YOU CAN'T FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND STUDENTS MATRICULATED RESET
THEN THE BUYER EDUCATION BUT
ALSO FOR WHAT GREATER IMPACT.
THAT HAS ON ALL OF US IN THE
IMPACT THAT WE WILL HAVE ON THE
WORLD AN APP ON THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALTHOUGH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE IF
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND. THAT THE
EFFECTIVE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IN CONCERT AND SHARED. PROBLEMS
REQUIRED SHARE. AT LEAST. I
WILL. TO SAY FOR ME AND I. THE
SOUTHERN IT LIVING IN A YOU
SICK- I. WE'RE GET A LITTLE BIT
NOISE AND MIGHT ONE TO SLOW
DOWN JUST A SO THE OPERA COULD
HE YOU I DON'T KNOW IF HAVE
VIEWED THE- OF WHAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON BUT I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE COVER
THOSE BASES SO WE CAN BE SURE
AND GET YOUR TESTIMONY. AGAIN
FORGIVE ME FOR INTERRUPTED-
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
SENATOR MY APOLOGIES. ALTHOUGH
YOU THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE IT'S CLEAR HE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE TECHNICAL
HIGHER EDUCATION WORKING
CULTURE AND SHARED PROBLEMS
REQUIRE SHARED COMMUNITY. I GOT
THE CHANCE TO LEARN SO MUCH
FROM TRUSTEE WILL. I KNOW HE
SERVED AVENUE AND A MENTOR TO
SO MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY YOUNG PEOPLE. HI
ARE YOU ALSO SUPPORT IN THE WAY
BY SUPPORTING JUSTIN WILLIAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MATAMATA RAIDER NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. BETTER COME FROM LINE
OF TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN WITH. PERFECT MY NAME IS
THE TRIAL THE VASQUEZ I SERVE
IN MULTIPLE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND WORK AT THE
SENIOR DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVE
FOR ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
LOUIS DREYFUS OF THE FORTY
SEVENTH DISTRICT. TODAY I HOPE
TO WITNESS THE HISTORICAL
MOMENT AS YOU ALL APPROVED THE
APPOINTMENT OF JOSEPH WILLIAM
AS A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. I AM A PRODUCT OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
AND I THIRD TO EXCLUDE INTEREST
THE FOR THE SAMITY NO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. JOHNSON HAD
UP LIFTED ME EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. I CAN SAY FIRST HAND JUST
HOW IMPACTFUL JOSEPH ADVOCACY
HAVE BEEN. ITSELF WITH
LEADERSHIP HAS HELPED ME AND
MANY OTHER UNDER REPRESENTED
AND UNDERSERVED STUDENTS SUCH
AS MYSELF. JOSEPH IS A CHAMPION
FOR EQUITY AND INCLUSION MOST
ESPECIALLY IN EDUCATION. C.
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
SERVED AND THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS ARE AT THE
DECISION MAKING PEOPLE. SHE
ENCOURAGES US ALL TO TAKE
OWNERSHIP OF OUR EDUCATION AND
OUR LIFE. I KNOW HE WILL BE AN
AMAZING SERVANT LEADER ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS I TRUST THAT OUR
STUDENTS WILL BE IN GOOD HANDS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THE INLAND EMPIRE REPRESENTED
IT IS LONG OVERDUE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU THAT'LL CONFIRM LINE OF
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHY
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO
YOU HAVE A TIME YOU. OKAY WE'LL
GO TO THE FOLLOWING LINE OF
LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES WE CAN. HELLO THIS IS A
PASTOR SAM CASEY- PASTOR NEW
LIFE CHRISTIAN CHURCH IN THE
CITY OF FONTANA CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED FOR
PROSTHETIC ENGAGEMENT OR COLD.
IT GIVES ME EXTREME HONOR AND
I'M HUMBLED BY THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SUPPORT AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR BROTHER TRUSTEE
JOSEPH WILLIAMS WHO IS YES
THAT'S A MEMORABLE STALWART IN
OUR COMMUNITY OF EQUITY. HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION OF STUDENTS.
ZACKS INTO THINK. CRITICAL AND
WE THANK GOD FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY THAT HE ADDS AS
MUCH AS MORRELL DIGESTED
MOMENTS AGO THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT NOT ONLY FOR JOBS AND
BUT REALLY FOR OUR COMMUNITY
HERE- IN THE REGION BUT
CERTAINLY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO I STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH WITH NOT ONLY
JOSEPH'S FAMILY BUT CERTAINLY
BOTH OF YOU IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OR SPEAKING ON HIS
BEHALF TODAY. KERN AND
CELEBRATE THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
TRUSTEE JOSEPH WILLIAMS- HE'S
AN AMAZING LEADER. AND A
CHAMPION FOR ALL THAT IS GREAT
AND POSITIVE- FOR STUDENTS. AS
WELL AS STAFF. TWENTY WILL BE
OF SUPPLY IN A- TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS GREAT STATE
THAT WE CAL. APALACHEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MATT A
COMPROMISED OF THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN GO AHEAD HI
MY NAME. YOU CAN HEAR ME LOUD
AND CLEAR YES WE CAN'T. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- I'M HONORED MY
NAME IS EDWARD BRADLEY ARE
SERVICES- JUVENILE JUSTICE
COMMISSIONER. FOR SUMMER YOU
KNOW COUNTY DELINQUENCY
COMMISSION- ALSO SERVE AS A
ADVOCATE IN SOCIAL JUSTICE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT- OF SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT. I
SPEAK AND I REGARD TO DEAL
WILLIAM- DIRECTLY DEALS. AND
THE FOUNDING MEMBER OF YOUTH
ACTION PROJECT FOR NEARLY
FIFTEEN YEARS. ARE YOU THE
ACTION PROJECT IF YOU DON'T
KNOW IS A PREMIER ORGANIZATION
HERE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE-
PROVIDING OVER SIXTY PLUS JOBS-
TO YOU- EXITING HIGH SCHOOL AND
GIVING OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN COLLEGE. TO
MENTOR AND OF BE THOSE
ADVOCATES FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WELL I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
NOT ONLY WORKING THERE
REGULARLY- WITH THOSE STUDENTS
BUT- WHAT TO KNOW STUDENTS
TRANSFORM THEIR LIVES. AND
THERE'S JONES WHO IS APPOINTED
IN THIS POSITION I WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND THAT HE STATED THAT
THE POLLS OF WHAT THE NEEDED IN
THIS COMMUNITY- HE WORKS
DIRECTLY AND TARGETING
STRATEGIC WAYS AND BETTERING
SYSTEMS IMPACTS BEST PRACTICES.
AS AS AN ADVOCATE YOU KNOW-
THERE'S A SAYING THAT WE HADN'T
USED ACTION PROJECT GET IT
REFERS TO NOTHING FOR US
WITHOUT US. AND SO- DEMI IS
THAT YOU KNOW HE- DID THAT THE
PULSE OF WHAT THE STUDENTS ARE
NEEDING IS THAT THE PULSE OF
WHAT WORKERS- OR- EMPLOYERS ARE
NEEDING. AND BECAUSE OF THAT
THAT PUTS HIM IN A VERY UNIQUE
POSITION IN THIS APPOINTMENT I
STAND IN AGREEMENT AS YOU
APPROVE THIS- APPOINTMENT FOR A
TRUSTEE JOSEPH WILLIAMS- I
SPEAK- YOU KNOW NOT ONLY AS A
SOMEONE WHOSE WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THEM BUT I'M AS BROTHER.
AND HIS BROTHER HE IS IN A
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS WORK AND SO
I JUST SAID IN AGREEMENT THAT
YOU APPROVE THIS POSITION THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH OUR- THANK YOU.
NEXT TO PLEASE. THANK YOU A
COMPARABLE I OF TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS THE- THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS COUNTY ROGER AND I THE
CURRENT BOARD PRESIDENT CAMERA
DON'T PRETTY UNIFIED SCHOOL.
AND FOUND OF YOUNG WOMAN
EMPOWERMENT COUNTY. I DON'T
CONSIDER A ON THE BOARD OF
ERROL HAD UNITED WAY WITH
MISTER WILLIAMS AND JORDAN
WILLIAMS HAD. BEEN A HUGE AND
ROLE MODEL IN THE TAMPERING
CITY HERE KERN HELP TEACHING AT
CHANGE FROM TWELVE HIGH WINDS
SERVING THOSE SIR STUDENTS
WHICH I ALSO PRODUCT STAMMERING.
YEAH COLLEGE HE HAS BEEN
HACKABLE SURVEYS THAT HAS MORE
WITH THAT IS TRUE TO MORE. WE
ARE GREAT FOR WORK THAT HE DID
A THE AGREEMENT MANY OF OUR
STATE THAT HAVE HAD ACT. SHOULD
YOU NEED COLLEGE HAD. PRECIADO
PALMER HE IS A YEAR ONE AND ON
FEDERAL. ARE HERE AND I JUST.
RECOMMEND THIS APPOINTMENT FOR
MISTER WILLIAMS THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
COME LINE A THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
A- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ATKINS
AND MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THAT. TO THANK I COULD
YOU KNOW LENDING WITH THE CAN
TO UP. BUSINESS APART AFTER
BECAUSE THE TO THE- TO THE. A
PRODUCT OF THE CALIFORNIA TO
CALL SYSTEM MR LOW HAS. HIS
LIFE TO CAREER. LISTING AT
POWERING AND UNDER YOU ACROSS
THE INTERNET AND WOULD YOU LIKE
STREET. IN NINETEEN EIGHT HE
FOUNDED THE ACTION PROJECT A
PROGRAM THAT THE COURT IN THE
DROUGHT THE BALLOT THE FIELD
NECESSARY TO ECONOMIC OF CLASS.
ADDITIONALLY AS A MEMBER OF THE
AND CAN COLLEGE DISTRICT
ATTEMPT. APART OF THE AFTER
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HOW TRUSTEE
TO BUT THE- MISTER WILLIAMS
ABOUT THE- I THANK. I'VE BEEN
ON THE GROUND PRACTITIONER THE
POLISH WILL WATCH THAT. THE
BOARDED UP. NOT ONLY DOES
MISTER WILLIAMS WITH PROVIDE
CAREER. ADDITIONAL CONFLICT NET
BALL. AT THE BOTTOM THE IN
EMPIRE MISTER WILL RECORD THAT
THOUSAND OF BLACK. YOU DON'T
ACROSS THE FROM ENTERPRISE MAKE
OF ONE OF POSSIBLE WE GET YOU
TO THE OPEN A- TO SUCCEED AT A-
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
ACTIVISTS ARE. MISTER WILLIAMS
WILL BE THE ONLY BLACK MAN ON
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS BRING IN
CENTRAL PERSPECTIVE AND
REPLICATION TO REPORT WHICH
REPRESENTS NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND BLACK
STUDENTS ARE 64% OF ALL BLACK
UNDERGRADUATE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION. MISTER
WILLIAMS AND REPRESENTATIVE OF
OUR STATE PAPERS STUDENT
POPULATION HAS EXCEPT COURSE
I'M AT THE GYM MAKE ME LAUGH
EVERY POINT OF HIS CAREER.
FINALLY HE HAS NOT PLAYED TO
APPEAR TODAY- WE ARE ALSO TO
POINT SUPPORT FOR THE
APPOINTMENT OF MR SEATBELT
CALIFORNIA DID EIGHT MISSION.
ANOTHER LONG TIME CHAPLAIN BOB.
WE RESPECT REQUEST YOUR INCOME
OF THE FUTURE OF THE PROGRAM AT
THE KNOW JUST BUCKLEY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE YOU VERY
MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LETTER COME FROM LINE OF
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. ALEX OBLIGATION.
I DIDN'T AS SIR I DIDN'T HEAR
WE CAN HEAR YOU BUT I DIDN'T
HEAR YOUR NAME IF YOU IF YOU
GAVE YOUR NAME WE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT. GO AHEAD. OKAY
ALEX LOVE THANK YOU. HI
PROBLEMS PARTICULARLY HONORED
TO WITNESS THIS PROCESS IN
HISTORY IN THE MAKING ALL THAT
I JUST BE STRAIGHTFORWARD I WAS
ONE OF THOSE TO HATE SCHOOL I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU ALL BUT
COULD ALSO LESSEN MY PAIN I WAS
TOLD I WAS NEVER GOING TO
SUCCESSFUL AND- THE DALLAS
SPECIALIST TO THE HIGH SCHOOL
DROPOUT AND ACTORS HAVE PEOPLE
MARK CORNER. CAGEY TO ADVOCATE.
FOR AFTER. SO VETERANS MATTERS
PEOPLE I JOSEPH LIKE PEOPLE
THAT. AND NOW TODAY SURE. AND
I'M ALSO COUPON AND I CONCERN
AND SHUTTLE AND ALSO BASED IN
THE CENTER AND I THINK ATTACKS
SHE WAS. AND ALSO WERE WITH YOU
ACTION CHARGES THAT WOULD
OBLIGATION TO A BRILLIANT AS
THE NUMBERS NON. A NUMBER OF
SAN BERNARD DINO. THIS DISTRICT
AND THE SPEC. GERMANY YOU KNOW
HOW ONE PERSON THANKS THE HOW
CRASH WITHOUT SEVEN. RIGHT ALSO
CITY THAT WAS. BY IN TWENTY
THREE. THE CITY THAT WAS
BANKRUPT SOFTBANK INCLUDE
TWELVE. YOU KNOW A LOT OF-
NARRATIVES COMMISSION OF YOU
KNOW NOT GOOD NOW. THE PEOPLE I
CHOSE. HELP SHAPE OF THE
NARRATIVE IS JUST. THEY BRING
WHOLE. HOST OF THIS HIGHER OLD
WITH. OF YOUNG PEOPLE. TRYING
TO GET BACK TO JOB AND TO.
RIGHT ABSOLUTELY WE ARE A
PROFESSOR WHO ALL TIME FROM TO
GET BACK TO TRY GIVE YOU SEE.
AND ACTUAL PROJECT WHICH IS
ALSO FOR OF EVERYTHING JUST
ABSOLUTELY. AND WE DON'T GET
THAT SIR JIM WE. I'M HERE AT M.
L. A. AFTER SYSTEM BUT FAMILY
LONGER STORMS CAR. SO I AM ON
IT AND I DON'T. TO KNOW THAT I
KNOW JUST BROKE. AND THE THAT
HE WAS ON THE WORK MORE.
INSPIRED ME TO MOVE TO. SO YOU
WANT TO START OUT DIDN'T
ACTUALLY. THE PEOPLE WHO CARES.
HAVE NOT GIVEN UP. AND YOU KNOW
CONSIDER DOING THAT WORK WE
STAND WITH YOU JUST AS WELL.
FURTHER OFF SUPPORTING Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE'LL START BACK
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE AND HERE STILL IS NO ONE
HERE FROM THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK
OUR IN PERSON SO LET ME LOOK AT
ROOM ONE TWELVE. AGAIN SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE PODIUM IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MADAM MODERATOR
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK TO YOU
NOW FORANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU HERE
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
MATAMATA RAIDER- WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE AND
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION. I
MOVE APPROVAL OF THE SENATOR
LAYERED HAS MOVED APPROVAL OF
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROVE I WROTE AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYERED AYE. AYE THE EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT FIVE ATKINS AYE ATKINS
AYE. FIVE TRUSTEE WILLIAMS
CONGRATULATIONS AND I
IMPRESSIVE GROUP OF SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT- IT SPEAKS TO WHY-
YOU'VE BEEN APPOINTED TO THE RE
APPOINTED TO THIS POSITION SO
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOU ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LET ME SEE IF
WE NEED TO TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK. YES WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
A FIVE MINUTE RECESS AND WILL
BE BACK IN FIVE MINUTES THANK
YOU.
AND THE LET ME SEE AN
IMMEDIATELY- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- CERTAINLY WE
APPRECIATED- THIS ORDER AND WHO
WILL BE THE NEXT APPOINTMENT
FOR CONSIDERATION MEMBER STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT BOARD. SO
LET ME SAY WELCOME TO YOU I
INVITE YOU TO MAKE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS- RECOGNIZER
ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU WOULD
LIKE IT'S BEEN SUPPORTIVE AND
THEY WILL GO RIGHT TO COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER- THEN AND IT
IS TRULY MY HONOR TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
CONFIRMING MY APPOINTMENT TO
THE CASTERS BOARD. CERTAINLY IN
I AM CALLING MY ACTIVE
RETIREMENT AND LOOKING FOR THE
RIGHT WORDS THEIR LIFE CHAPTER.
HAVING HAVING SPENT A FORTY
YEAR CAREER AND GLOBAL FINANCE.
AND INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO
MANAGEMENT. SERVING ON THE
TELSTRA'S BOARD HAS VERY
SPECIAL MEANING TO ME AND YET
NOT ONLY BRING MY PROFESSIONAL
CREDENTIALS AND EXPERIENCE. AND
THE EXPERIENCE DO YOU SHARE ANY
WITH A DEEP COMMITMENT TO
RESPONSIBLE STEWARDSHIP. I'M
ALSO A PRODUCT OF K. TO TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS A RETIREE AND OF
COURSE THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. I WAS RAISED WITH A
COMMITMENT TO SERVICE AND I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IF CONFIRMED. TO
CONTINUE TO APPLY MY SKILLS AND
EXPERIENCE TO MAKE
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH PURPOSE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO LEARN. IF I
COULD MAYBE JUST GIVE A FEW-
THANKS PLEASE I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR HIS
APPOINTMENT AND HIS TRUST. CAL
ST STE AND STAFF BEEN
TREMENDOUS TO WORK WITH THEIR
COMMITMENT TO EXCELLENCE VALUES
COLLABORATION. AND RESULTS. AND
THE ALMOST ONE MILLION CAL
STIRS MEMBERS FOR THEIR DEEPLY
VALUED WORK IN IMPACT. AND THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP TO SECURE THE
FINANCIAL FUTURE AND SUSTAIN
TRUST OF CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATORS.
NO TO THAT YOU HAVE MY FULL
COMMITMENT TO BE A SOUND PRETTY
SCARY THE BEST WORK MEMBER I
CAN BE IF CONFIRMED. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND THE COURTS RESPONDING TO
YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MR MAJORITY LEADER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO WORK KICK US
OFF. OKAY NO QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROWTH AND THANK YOU
MADAM FOR TEMP I. THANK YOU
MISS- DANFORD AT TAKING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE US I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
OPENING REMARK AS WELL- WHAT'S
YOUR OVERALL THOUGHTS ON
CASTERS AND CASTER IS CAL STIRS
UNFUNDED PENSION LIABILITY AND
**** CAL STIRS TAKE ANY
ADDITIONAL STEPS. TO IMPROVE
THE FUNDS AND SUSTAINABILITY.
THANK YOU SENATOR- AND I REALLY
THANKS TO EVERYBODY FOR THE
HARD WORK THAT WENT INTO
ESTABLISHING THE FULL FUNDING
PLAN. AND IT REALLY IS I KNOW
THE PRODUCT OF A LOT OF HARD
WORK OF EVERYBODY TOGETHER. AND
WE HAD OUR MOST RECENT- REVIEW
OF IT IT'S CONTINUOUSLY REVIEW
THIS YOU KNOW AND I FEEL VERY
POSITIVE ABOUT REMAINING ON THE
PATH TO FULL FUNDING BY TWENTY
FORTY SIX ASK FOR THE PLAN. AND
DECEMBER BOARD MEETING WE DID
HAVE A FULL REVIEW AND WE ARE
STILL EXPECTED TO BE YOU KNOW
JUST NEARLY 1100% THAT. OKAY AM
I JUST HAVE TO MORE I'M SORRY-
FREE FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AS A
BOARD MEMBER AND WITH YOUR
BACKGROUND IN INVESTMENT AND
FINANCE- WHAT REFORMS DO YOU
THINK WOULD BE NEEDED SO THAT
WE DEFINITELY DO. REACH THAT
GOAL BY TWENTY FORTY SIX OF A
SUSTAINABLE A RETIREMENT
PROGRAM. EXCELLENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN ON THIS BOARD FOR SIX
MONTHS AT THIS POINT AND- I'D
LOVE TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION WHAT I HAVE SEEN.
IS THAT IT'S A VERY THOUGHTFUL
PLANS AND THAT THE INVESTMENTS
AS YOU KNOW ARE APPROXIMATELY
60% OF THE RETURN- OF THE
CONTRIBUTION TO GET TO THAT.
AND IT'S JUST CRITICAL AS WE'RE
DOING TO CONTINUE TO EVALUATED
ON AN ONGOING BASIS. AND IT
THIS POINT IT IT REALLY DOES
APPEAR- THAT WE'RE ON TRACK
WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE IT
AND I THINK FOR US ALL TO
REMAIN IN PARTNERSHIP. OVER THE
COURSE OF THIS TIME PERIOD TO
ENSURE THAT. THANK YOU AND I DO
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
PUTTING SOMEBODY ON THIS BOARD
THAT DOES HAVE THAT BACKGROUND-
THAT DOES HAVE THAT BACKGROUND
THE SENATE PROTEIN JUST LOOKED
AT ME BECAUSE I DON'T APPLY TO
HIM VERY OFTEN. IT IDEAL BODY
IN HER FOR HER. TAKING SOMEONE
WITH YOUR BACKGROUND TO
ACTUALLY HANDLE THIS ISSUE THAT
WE FACE WITH OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND TEACHERS THAT HAVE
RETIRED IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY DO YOU ANTICIPATE
A LARGE NUMBER OF RETIREMENTS
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND IF SO. DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THE FUNDING MODEL-
WILL BE IMPACTED. I REGRET
ANOTHER GREAT QUESTION I WISH
WE HAD THAT CRYSTAL BALL BUT
WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT THE
PALLISTER'S TEAM HAS BEEN
TERRIFIC THEY DO- THEY SURVEYED
THAT RETIREES ON MONTHLY BASIS
WE BEGAN TO SEE SOME UPTICK IN
RETIREMENTS IN THE BEGINNING OF
OUR FISCAL YEAR- AND JUST
STARTING IN THE JULY TIME FRAME
WE DID AT QUESTIONS. AND CAN
CONFIRM THAT A NUMBER OF THE
UPTICK IN RETIREMENT ASSISTED A
PANDEMIC RELATED REASONS AT THE
SAME TIME WE'VE BEEN IN
COORDINATION WITH OUR ACTUARY
TEAM AND OTHERS AND AT THIS
POINT WE DON'T SEE A TRAP AND
THAT'S MATERIAL- THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY UNDER RIGHT BUT IT IS
UNDER CONSTANT EVALUATION. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT.
THE YOU VERY MUCH FOR ANSWERING
MY QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- AND
SENATOR I LOOK TO YOU BECAUSE I
KNEW THOSE WOULD BE THE KINDS
OF QUESTIONS YOU WOULD ASK
RELATED TO FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY- AND I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THAT. I EXPECTED NO
LESS- CENTER LAYERED YES BUT
THE SINCE I KNOW THIS IS A NON
PREFER I DO LOOK FORWARD TO THE
TRANSCRIPT OF ONE PART OF YOUR
COMMENT. TO ABLE TO CIRCULATE
WHY DO IT- THE- OF AND I'M
SORRY WE DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE
TO MEET. A AND- I ACTUALLY.
SINCE I HAVE A MOTHER ON A VERY
MODEST PENSION FROM YOUR SYSTEM
I DO HEAR ABOUT THE OPERATIONS
REGULARLY. AND I HAD JUST ONE
QUESTION IN A WAY IT'S A FOLLOW
UP ON SENATOR GROVES AND THAT
IS YOU ARE INVOLVED IN
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT. AND ONE
OF THE INTERESTING DYNAMICS
WITH CAL STIRS IS SET AND WITH
PURSES WHILE. IS THERE SUCH A
FLUCTUATION IN THE ECONOMY AND
SUCH A FLUCTUATION IN THE
INVESTMENTS. THAT ARM THEIR
CALLS. TO ACT WHEN EUROPE ONE
END OR ANOTHER THERE'S A CALL
TO ACT WHEN THE ECONOMY IS
REALLY DOWN THAT SOMEHOW WE
READ TO DO SOMETHING DRAMATIC
AND THERE'S A CALL TO DO OTHER
THINGS WHEN THE ECONOMY IS WAY
UP. HOW DO YOU MANAGE. THE SORT
OF POLICY IN THE FACE OF THE
FLUCTUATIONS TO BE CONSISTENT
AND BE TRUE TO WHAT THE LONG
TERM OF VISION OR LONG TERM
FACTS MIGHT BE. THANK YOU
SENATOR- WHAT THE IT STARTS
WITH THE POLICY AS YOU NOTED
AND HAVING A POLICY THAT'S
DESIGNED TO MEET THE EXPECTED
RETURN OVER THE LONG TERM AND
HOLLISTER SAYS A LONG TERM
INVESTOR. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
BE MINDFUL OF THE SHORT TERM SO
THAT NEEDS TO BRING INTO A FACT
INVESTMENT VOLATILITY AND
LIQUIDITY NEEDS. SO THESE ARE
THE FACTORS THAT WE BALANCE-
THAT THAT IN SETTING THE
POLICIES AND THAT THE STAFF.
MANAGES ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND
CONTINUES TO REPORT THAT BACK
TO US SO. THE DANGER IS AND
TRYING TO REALLY FOLLOW SHORT
TERM SWINGS AND THIS LATEST-
EXPERIENCE WITH THE- MOST IN A
SWIFT DOWNDRAFT OF THE
INVESTMENT MARKETS IN THE
ECONOMY THAT WE'VE SEEN AND
THEN MOST RAPID INCREASE. IN
THE MARKETS WHERE WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE VERY REAL ISSUES
THAT WE ALL FACE EVERY DAY- IS
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THAT SO IT'S
VERY COMPLEX- AS FOR SAM AND
OUR CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER
LIKES TO SAY WE'RE WE'RE CRUISE
SHIP. AND A CRUISE SHIP FOR
GOOD REASON TO KEEP AN EYE ON
THE LONG RUN WE KEEP AN EYE AND
QUIDDITY. AND WE KEEP AN EYE ON
SOUND. PRACTICES AND POLICIES
TO MEET OUR OBJECTIVES I AM NOT
A- ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
BECAUSE THE CURSE ME I DON'T
KNOW. IT USED TO BE THAT THERE
WAS- AN INCREASE THAT HAD TO
BE. CONNECTED FOR THE
PENSIONERS EVERY YEAR A. N.
THERE WAS TALK OF MAKING IT A
STANDARD 2% INCREASE OR
WHATEVER DO YOU KNOW WHAT. THE
STATUS OF THAT IS AT THIS POINT.
SLASH THERE ARE- YOU KNOW I
WOULD LOVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON IF I THINK I KNOW I WANT TO
BE SURE I GET THE CORRECT.
THERE WELL I HAD THIS
EXPERIENCE THAT MAYBE OTHER
MEMBERS OF HAD. THAT MY MOTHER
GOT A LEGISLATIVE ALERT ABOUT
THE 2% AND MAILED TO ME WRITING
ACROSS THE TOP IS THIS TRUE. I
THOUGHT MAYBE I DO A LITTLE
PREVENTIVE ACTION RIGHT HERE. I
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO THE
RESPONSE THANK YOU. YEAH AND SO
WONDERFUL KNOWING THAT WE'RE
ALSO WORKING ON BEHALF OF YOUR
MOTHER'S PART OF. THANK YOU.
SHE'LL BE BESIDE HERSELF TO
HEAR THAT YOU CAME UP AT A
HEARING IN. BOB YOU KNOW I. WON
NEVER ASK. A LADY HER AGE BUT
YOUR MOM IS. HOW OLD NINETY SIX
NINETY SIX TO THE POINT TO
WHERE YOU DO HAVE TO HAVE
NINETY SIX AND NINETY SIX AND A
HALF- REALLY. WONDERFUL HOW
FORTUNATE YOU ARE. OF SENATOR
BATES- THANK YOU MA'AM FOR
TENANTS I JUST LIKE TO SAY
MOTHERS ALWAYS ASKING IS IT
TRUE. THAT JOB REALIZE ABOUT
GOING TO JOHN. ANYWAY I THINK
YOU MISTER THAN FOUR YEARS.
COURTESY OF- BACKGROUND AND OF
A MY COLLEAGUES OF BASICALLY
AFTER QUESTIONS THE TSUNAMI
THAT MIGHT BE FACING US WITH
THE NUMBER OF RETIREMENTS FROM
CROSS CAL STIRS IS ALWAYS
SOMETHING THAT'S RIGHT OUT
THERE IN FRONT OF YOU I'M SURE.
ALSO OF SOUNDS LIKE YOU YOU'RE
ANTICIPATING THAT I DID SERVE
ON THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND AS SUCH WE HAD
A LOT OF INTERACTION WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM AND WHEN WE
HIT THE GREAT RECESSION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. TWO THOUSAND
NINE AND FEDERAL WE HAD A REAL
YOU KNOW BOTH IN TERMS OF
WHETHER WE WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW MEET UP. THE
PENSION OBLIGATIONS THAT YEAR
SO THOSE ARE ALWAYS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU AND IT SOUNDS TO
ME LIKE YOU ARE ANTICIPATING
THAT AND ARE THE PLAN AND THAT
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY THERE FOR
ABOUT FOR ABOUT THREE LEE GREAT
TO HEAR- I DO HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF COMMENTS ABOUT WHO'S
KIND OF WRITING CAL STIRS WHO'S
THE CEO AND I. UNDERSTAND FROM
OUR INTERVIEW OUR STAFF
INTERVIEWING ARE YOU THAT THE
CEO IS RETIRING AT THE END OF
JUNE AND YOU ARE STE OUR FAMILY
INVOLVED IN THE RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE SUCH A DEPTH OF
KNOWLEDGE COULD YOU GIVE US A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF THAT EFFORT
WITHOUT REVEALING ANYTHING
THAT. MIGHT NOT BE SOMETHING
YOU WANT TO PUT OUT THERE ARE
NONE. IN IN THE GREATER
COMMUNITY BUT TO BE INTERESTING
TO HEAR ABSOLUTELY SAID JACKIE
NANCY IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME AND
TO REFLECTS THE YELLOW IF
YOU'RE TIRING AT THE END OF
JUNE. AND A SEARCH COMMITTEE
WAS FORMED LAST YEAR A SEARCH
CONSULTANT WAS ALSO HIRED AND
THEN A NUMBER OF US ON THE
BORDER ON THAT SEARCH
SUBCOMMITTEE AND SO THAT
PROCESS IS WELL UNDER WAY AND
WE WERE- HAVE SOME TERRIFIC IN
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES AND-
THAT'S PROBABLY ABOUT WHAT I
CAN SAY AT THIS TIME- BUT IT
SAID IT'S SO. TERRIFIC THIS AND
WE ARE STILL TERRIFIC CANDID.
WHAT'S GREAT TO HEAR THAT
TREMENDOUS LEADER THERE ALSO IS
A SUCCESS PLAN IN EVERY THAT WE
IN PLACE. FIRST OF ALL CONTINUE
TO KEEP AN EYE AND THAT ALL
GOES. EIGHT THANK YOU FOR THOSE
WITH THING YOU. THE NEW. ARE
FOR YOUR ON. THIRTY IN AND
CERTAINLY. ON YOUR NOMINATION.
THANK YOU US SENATOR BATES AND-
I CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUES AS
SOMEONE WHO SERVED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND HAD TO DEAL WITH-
PENSION ISSUES ARE AND
CERTAINLY LEARNED A LOT DURING
SOME VERY DIFFICULT TIMES I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD ABOUT THE LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE AND HOW IMPORTANT
THAT IS OF COURSE OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAVE HAVE REFER SAID
AS WELL. I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE HERE. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF WE HAVE NO ONE HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I WILL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE AND- STILL
SEE THAT WE HAVE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THERE SO MADAM
MODERATOR I AM COMING BACK TO
YOU FOR THE LAST TIME TO ASK
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE AND IF YOU
WOULD- FIFTY UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
THE SUUDAAN. THANK YOU FEWER IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. ONE ZERO FIRST SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE NOBODY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN
JUST A MOMENT TO CONCLUDE- I
WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
AND AGAIN WE HAVE NO ONE HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
I STILL SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SAVANNAH MODERATOR I AM
ALREADY BACK WITH YOU TO SEE IF
YOU HAVE PEOPLE. WHO WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
CAN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NOBODY
IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE SO
MUCH YOUR HELP TODAY MADAM
MODERATOR- I WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR A MOTION.
WITH AND AGAIN MULTIPLE MOVERS
BUT I WILL RECOGNIZE THE
MAJORITY LEADER AS THE MOTION
WAS MADE AT MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL OUR ROLE. GROWTH I
GROW BY HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG BY LAYERED HI HI
BATES I THINK IT'S AYE ATKINS
HI I CAN SIGN. IT IS UNANIMOUS
AND- WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND- CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LUCRECE YOUR
SUPPORT AND ALL OF YOUR SERVICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY LET
ME THANK ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AND IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN OUR OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION AND
PARTICULARLY OUR STENOGRAPHER-
WE HAD A FEW- INTERESTING
MOMENTS WERE WE WEREN'T SURE WE
COULD HERE SO LET ME JUST THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR COMMITTEE. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
NOW GO INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION
THANK YOU.